hey GQ I'm Olivia Rodrigo and these are
my 10 Essentials
[Music]
this is like an industrial strength
weighted blanket I think someone gave me
one of these for Christmas one year now
I get everyone else this for Christmas
because it's like the best gift I've
ever been given some people hate it some
people say it feels like suffocating but
to me it's just the best type of
Suffocation I love it every time I get
into a hotel bed I like get in and I'm
like hmm something's not right because
I'm missing this and it's actually very
cumbersome to travel with so I sometimes
just have to do without it like I don't
know how you'd put this in a little
carry-on
feels so safe right now
this is very important this is my actual
Journal it's kind of scary to have it
out in the open here I'm so terrified of
losing my journals that's like my worst
fear when I was kind of having trouble
overcoming lots of the pressure of of
making a sophomore record I read the
hardest way in one of the big tenets of
the artist's way is doing your morning
pages so it's like three pages long hand
stream of Consciousness in the morning
like first thing you do when you wake up
I think for me it's just nice to be able
to write something down and not judge it
in the moment I think that's the whole
point of doing the learning pages is
just to be like this is stream of
Consciousness what I'm feeling I'm not
gonna judge it too harshly or wonder if
it's gonna make any money or be
criticized or whatever this thing really
lovely about that I feel like I've been
pretty diligently keeping
some sort of journal or diary since I
was like 13 years old and so I just have
this like Rolodex of all of my feelings
for a long time and it's nice to kind of
look back at issues that I thought were
going to be world ending and be like ah
that worked out totally fine it made me
who I am that kind of just like puts
things into perspective you know
[Music]
so these are the guts Rings rings in
general are a huge essential for me I
don't go anywhere without these rings I
feel very naked without them if I ever
go on vacation or something and get
tanned I have like weird tan lines on my
hands because I refuse to take my rings
off my producer's wife Emily actually
made these she's an incredible jewelry
designer I named the album guts for many
different reasons I love the word I
think it has so many cool meanings means
intuition it means courage spilling your
guts is just like telling all your
secrets to everyone which I feel like is
just very synonymous with songwriting
and it's just a cool four-letter word I
think it looks cool it's very like
evocative I don't know they all are kind
of sentimental to me this one my
producer Dan got from me for Christmas
and he's one of my closest friends and
my parents got me this one for my 18th
birthday it's a vintage store and I
think it's really special this one my
makeup artist on High School Musical I
was filming this show and I was really
close with her and she helped me through
a lot and she got me this ring when we
wrapped and it says write the songs of
of your heart and on the inside it says
love Heidi and Dottie June which is her
dog her little French Bulldog actually
left for the Grammys two years ago and I
forgot my rings at home and I had to
freak out and luckily someone was still
home and I made them go to my house and
get the rings and bring them to me
because I was convinced that it was
going to be a terrible night if I didn't
have my rings it was some weird thing
I was actually Tick-Tock influenced into
buying this there's like a subculture on
Tick Tock that's just so obsessed with
the Stanley Cup and what you put in it
and the flavored Waters and the soda
concoctions and I was like I need this
this looks like it'll change my life and
it completely did I've gotten actually
so many of the people on my team and so
many my friends on the Stanley grind
with me I did live in Utah for a while
and Utah is the land of like specialty
craft sodas this is like what they put
the sodas in so it's like Diet Coke and
like coconut creamer and like lemon
juice and like all of this fun stuff to
like doctor up your sodas I'm into that
I'm very into that it's really fun
the next item is skinny pop I consume so
much skinny pop I inhale it Like Oxygen
it is just my favorite snack there's one
open bag of skinny pop on my piano at
all times on my desk at all times and
then in the kitchen at all times open
like just ready for me to consume I
truly
lots of days will eat like this entire
entire thing
so good I will bring this into the movie
theater because it's so much better than
the movie theater popcorn to me I'll
just sneak it into my bag oh well let's
see what other flavors they have kettle
corn I've never tried that popcorn mini
cakes
wow there's a whole skinny pop Cinematic
Universe I need to try
[Music]
this is my favorite perfume it's the
baccarat Rouge 540.
so good I have a candle of it too that I
burned in my house I've never was super
into perfume before I smelled this one
and I'm like this this is the one for me
because I don't love like smelling like
candy or like flowers or something but
this just smells like sort of like you
could maybe possibly just naturally
smell this way if you're like an angel
or something it like doesn't smell like
any smell that I could place lots of
people say that like if they'll like
smell this scent and I'm like somewhere
else they'll think of me and that's a
very high compliment
this is my family and they are
definitely one of my 10 Essentials I
need them for everything my mom and my
dad I'm an only child and this is us at
Rockefeller Center during Christmas time
last year yeah I love my family I
wouldn't be anything without them I
adore them going to New York this time
was a really fun time I really love
traveling with my parents I think it's
so fun to get to go new places with them
and I saw the Barbie movie the other day
with my mom and I was like wow it's a
Transcendent experience
this is my favorite book I think it's
the only book that I've read more than
once it's like the creative person's
Bible I've made so many of my friends
read it I like recommend it to everyone
I know I just think it's so incredible
it's it's all about like creativity and
discipline and the anxieties that come
along with creativity and how to remedy
those and it's just it's amazing
Elizabeth if you're out there
changed my life with this one it was so
good I actually read this for the first
time while I was making sour and I
actually don't think that the album
would have turned out the way that it
did had I not read this book it was so
instrumental in my creative journey
I literally cannot leave the house
without it not being hyperbolic I go
everywhere with this I
took Accutane for the first time this
year I had bad teenager skin and my lips
were so dry all the time and now I carry
this with me everywhere I go because
it's just so chapstick put it on
anything put on wounds the opportunities
are endless with Aquaphor I feel like
all these items I'm just doing
commercials for these brands
[Music]
these are
tar pics but I love playing guitar I
love writing songs on guitar I'm slowly
getting better took some lessons this
year
you know a few songs I learned how to
play guitar like a lot of it was just by
myself like learning songs I really love
to play and when you're just learning
how to play you know like pop songs in
your bedroom you just kind of like do it
intuitively like with your like your
fingertips but it always does sound
better when you use a pick but sometimes
it's just you just go back to what you
did when you were 15. my producer Dan is
always trying to get me to play with the
pick because he says it sounds better
and I agree with him so I'm trying
keeping these with me and I think I'm
definitely better at piano I'm more
comfortable playing it which is why I
think sometimes it's nice to go out of
your comfort zone and play something on
an instrument you're not so familiar
with so I've been playing a lot of
guitar lately I wrote Love is
embarrassing on guitar song Lacy was
written on guitar there are a lot of
guitar based songs on this album nice
beautiful finger Plucky guitar and
there's also some like really driving
hard-hitting more Punky guitar so I
gotta get my practice in before tour
thanks GQ these were my 10 Essentials I
hope you enjoyed check out my new album
guts if you haven't already bye
[Music]